Ngày Ngày Mà Thanh Sau đã dễn cấp cao về tríng xe đối ngoại bản nên gồn lịch mình châu Âu,
bà ca ra cá lã sánh báo sẽ cực kỳ quy hiểm và cục tốt cho bất kỳ ai,
nếu Iran Đống cửa, Irobean Hóc Mú s,
tuyến hẳng hải cúp tế sau khi Mỹ thế này không kích các cơ sật hận nhân của tế hiểu ràn.
Lần này ra tăng sau khi cúp của Iran Ngày hành hài Thanh Sau,
bỏ viểu về việc Đống Irobean Hóc Mú s,
quy định này đang chờ sự phía tròn của hội đồng ăn ninh cúp ra tuy cao Iran.
Ngày lập thức ngoại trường Mỹ mắt cố rù biểu cảnh báo,
việc Iran Đống cửa Irobean Hóc Mú s, sẽ là xài lập khủng hấp.
Ông rù biểu hò gọi đó là hành động tự sát về mặt kinh tế với chính Iran.
Chồng ý đó người phát ngôn bộ ngoại giao chú quốc quốc quốc quốc gia cầu,
cảnh báo bất kỳ hành động nào đe zua tuyến đường chính lực này,
đều có thể gây tổn hạnh nghiêm chào đến kinh tế toàn cao.
Dưới nơi hình thủy hẹp qua Irobean Hóc Mú s ở cửa vịch bà tư,
lần nơi chiếm khoảng 2 mần vấn trà mỏ đồng phương mại dụng mỏ trên biển tòn cao.
Vì vậy, nếu thế ra không cho phép các tổ khu ngộ trên trở rau,
và khi rốt đi qua Irobean Hóc Mú s tới chung quốc chú hầu,
và các khu vực tụi tuy đều đang lượng khác trên thế giới,
giá rau của thế tăng vọt và gây bất ổn cho nên kinh tế thế giới.
Theo một số dự báo giá rau của khả năng tăng tăng mư phần tràm,
ngay trong tuần đầu sau khi Irobean đại đống cửa.
Vì các tuần thay thế sẽ phải chü chỉ phí rất lớn,
trong việc bản sâu nhất, nếu ở biển bị đống cửa hòn toàn,
các chuyên gia dự đoán sáng rở của thế vọt lên một chăm ai mới
đến một chăm năm 2019 thăm chiết chạp 3.5.
Nếu sự đột kéo dài, trong mình sự Iran từ lâu đã xưa dụng
Irobean Hóc Mú s gì một lávài mà cả chính lượng,
nhưng bất chấp nhiều lần đean dòa trong quả khu, Iran vẫn chưa bao giờ thực sự đống cửa ở bên này.